One idea they're going to be debating here in the European Parliament next month is this.
If job-destroying robots are replacing tax-paying humans,
well, perhaps we need to tax the robots.
My proposal is that we monitor exactly what is happening on the job market,
on the employment sector.
And if robots are taking over more jobs than new jobs are created,
we will be, or most of member states and of the governance,
we'll be in a difficult position to collect enough money
to finance all the services that we need.
So if this is the case, I think we should think on taxing robots
because someone has to pay for our normal life,
for the infrastructures, for the services that the government should provide to the people.
But how simple would this be?
Some robots are easy to identify.
The company replacing workers with a robot like Baxter here
would be relatively straightforward to tax.
But this wave of innovation is not all about the physical world.
Much of this revolution, though, is taking place out of sight,
inside reassuringly familiar-looking computer cases and server racks.
But these new machines are learning and thinking.
And learning and thinking is currently how much of humanity earns its living.
Welcome to SMAC.
It stands for smart accountancy.
This Berlin-based start-up has harnessed artificial intelligence
in an attempt to revolutionise the boring old accountancy profession.
The process looks familiar enough,
clients of the service will scan their invoices and receipts into a computer.
But inside, the software is doing something extraordinary.
Instead of human accountants looking at the documents,
the computer is figuring out the figures, adding them to the correct accounts.
Text on paper is pretty easy,
but then you have to interpret the text,
and the system has to know what is that number here and what is that number here,
and where is the text information on the receipt.
And that's interpreting the information,
and that's really, in many, many areas, a revolution that we are seeing.
For example, self-driving cars.
Is that a person crossing the street,
or is it just water on the street mirroring something?
Can I go on driving, or do I have to stop?
That's understanding, interpretation work.
And that's also the work that has to be done here for the accounting purposes.
The system really needs to do the interpretation.
At SMAC, they say this will lead to less mundane,
more interesting work for human accountants.
But again, the question is, how many of these human jobs will survive?
We are progressing very, very quickly in terms of innovation,
but we have no idea where we are heading and where we want to reach.
And I feel that at present, both governments and the private sector
are quite happy to rely on neoliberalism and market forces
and allow them to decide the direction of innovation.
And this is extremely dangerous.
How dangerous? Well, don't take it from me.
Want to know where we could be heading as a species?
Have a look at our friend Oliver here.
Just a century ago, millions of horses in the UK could earn their keep
in agriculture, in the mines, in industry, in transport.
The fact is that for almost every job that horses once monopolised,
today they're not worth their feed and stapling.
They couldn't give their labour away at any price.
We can only hope that the robots are a little more sympathetic to us
than we were to the horses.